decision fully agree let's play this
clip right here here's a clip that I
want to get your guys feedback on if
you're talking about being in a kid's
life are you informed though that I feel
very important you have kids they get
your throat
yeah are you informed now I know okay
this whole time I was worried about the
crazy person I'm banging slit my throat
it turns out I'm not corrupt 12 years
later kids in my throat that's exactly
fast forward this episode 15 years from
now Adam Saleh from the saucecast found
his son in his sleep and then myself
he's dead now that's just big well this
thing just got real dark anyway
play this clip over here you recently
had a good friend Andrew Tate on the
show on your Show recently it was a
great clip he's got very strong opinions
on what a man should do to have kids
especially with the crumbling Western
Civilization so let's play this clip now
what's your advice for a guy living in
the west and wants to have a family sure
I'll tell you what to do get a little
bit of money get on a plane fly to South
America find a girlfriend have a child
fly back to America when she says she
wants to move to America say no work go
visit be a family man you can be a
family man do not face this fear of
divorce rate keep your freedom live your
good life have your genetic progeny and
be fine without worrying about losing
the house getting destroyed financially
paying all your money away in child
support I'm absolutely deadly serious go
on to Cambodia I have three kids with
three women and there's your children
send them 100 bucks a month each work in
America and visit Cambodia three-time
team there's your children enjoy okay oh
my God so here we have to take very
powerful voice I would say I agree with
the vast majority of what Tate says even
the
stuff that seems to be triggering and
chauvinistic right here is a very very
slippery slope you're encouraging men to
knock up women all across the world not
raise your kids not be with your kids
send them send them a hundred dollars a
month to Cambodia or something
um and just not be in your kid's life I
think if I may this is very dangerous
advice okay so like here's the way I
process this
um do I want to get married and have
kids one day yeah that'd be great I know
all the risks you know throat all that
kind of good stuff everything that comes
with that I also
love America I'm not leaving America I'm
not going to Cambodia to find a wife
like believe me there's enough Latina
Colombian chicks in Miami I don't got a
[ __ ] fly to Medellin although shout
out to my friends in Medellin I'm
staying in America okay so I think this
is kind of a slippery slope where it's
like hey Western Civilization hey
America get the hell out of here the
system go find a Cambodian wife knock
her up not even a wife just knock her up
start having kids with Cambodian chicks
or Venezuelan chicks and send your kid a
hundred bucks every couple times a year
and next thing you know that's your life
I don't necessarily think that that is
the best game plan you talk about
wanting to have men and women together
and raising a family how do you feel
about our friend Tate saying something
like that would you want to get Knocked
Up by some dude just send you a couple
couple shekels a month every once in a
while you're raising the kids how do you
process that that would it be my first
choice yeah um I think a lot of times
when you ask men questions they're very
and so it's really interesting the like
lengths that men will go to to get the
outcome that they want so I think he's
saying that to like avoid you know the
laws in the U.S I think that's the
outcome he's looking for of course
um is that my first choice no
um and why is that not your first choice
I mean
I just think that it's better to have
two parents in the home I think most
studies will tell you it's better to
have two parents in the home gotcha so
it's like all right I'm not even having
kids what's that but I was I was
confused when I'm having kids is to be
with your kid
well apparently not because I thought
I've understood it like he's going back
and forth and he's still parenting but
he works in the U.S that's what I
understood it at okay so let's even say
that I think to be specific In that clip
and I get it it was taken out of context
it could have been an hour-long
conversation about different things but
we're commenting on that clip he
specifically said you go visit them
three times a year and you send them
money monthly oh he said three times yes
I don't think that's an ideal situation
no I don't think it's that controversial
for you to disagree with that by the way
Pearl no no I said that that wouldn't be
my first choice exactly okay three times
a year no I was just thinking like my
dad worked a lot and I've turned out
okay but three times a year that's you
probably need to hear that and by the
way your your parents have been together
for how many years I don't know like 30
roughly okay give or take five years
isn't that I guess in a perfect world
like so his thing is like it's almost
what you're saying know the risks be
informed don't get caught up the kids
are gonna get taken 90 of the time
anyway you're gonna end up paying
alimony risk risk risk
which is fair enough but isn't like the
best case scenario like let's go let's
go to happy town for a second you get
married you have communications some may
call it over communication these days I
don't get caught up on semantics you
have a prenup you communicate you have
sex with your wife she has sex with you
you have a happy marriage you have 2.3
kids you live in a happy home right you
roll Tide and you just do it together
like that to me seems like best possible
scenario nuclear family good home white
picket fence I get that we're not living
like Wally in the beaver days but that
lifestyle still exists let's not pretend
that you can't just be happily married
have kids and have a family why is that
so far fetched these days
it's just because we've seen so many
negative situations that it's like I
just think we live
we live first might have
you know what and is that more from the
women or the men
oh the women for sure if we're the ones
leaving Bingo yeah if we're the ones
that leave 70 to 80. okay you cannot
agree but that's a stat we leave 70 to
80 percent time yes but because the
woman's unhappy because of the way
they're being treated I mean that's it's
how is that upsetting like I mean
oh yeah I can't I mean what I mean what
percent of it's abuse I mean like
because women like we got upset over
stupid [ __ ] all the time and so if we're
gonna go basically it's hard to get
divorced especially for a lot of like
stay-at-home moms who don't have the
money to be able to pay for the divorce
attorney or to deal and be like okay
what am I gonna do after this like if a
woman is leaving it's because they are
extremely unhappy and it's an unhealthy
situation and either they're trying to
protect themselves or their children
no I mean I've had girls come on the
show they got divorced and like there
might be some that not like you can't
just say generally of anything I feel
like it's like a little bit it could be
there's a million dollars there's so
many different situations so many
different experiences and that's why we
can't just pigeonhole it to just one I
mean you're right there are different
experiences but he asked whose fault is
it and if we're leaving 70 to 80 percent
of the times that means we are ending
the marriage so and it's 90 of the time
if they're college educated yeah did you
go to college by the way yeah I done did
you initiate the divorce or did your
husband
uh I had to be pushed to do it oh so who
initiated the divorce yeah uh it was a
lot of talk and I called him up and
asked him again over and over each day
is this really what you want is this
really what you wanted he said yes file
the papers so this comes back to my
education thank you for that this comes
back to education like and communicating
like again you know we're done in five
minutes just saying everyone's got to
pee these days I would say I would say
Hey listen babe I love you you love me
but here are the stats okay I'm a
businessman I'm a stats person I get
you're an emotional person there's a 90
chance you went to college right baby
where'd you go again all right cool with
the UF awesome there's a 90 chance at
some point you're going to be unhappy
and want to leave me okay there's a high
likelihood that you're gonna get all the
kids and get all the money and I mean I
mean these kids these days over
communication yeah all right yeah
there's a high likelihood that I'm gonna
end up getting [ __ ] I love you you
love me but here's the sad reality of
things would a woman respond well to
something like that like how would a
woman respond to like here are the stats
I don't want to end up getting screwed
so before we do this thing together let
me just kind of over communicate and
like let me know what my concerns are
and this is why I need a prenup is that
going to turn a lot of women off what do
you think
yeah I was just thinking about like the
girls I talked to yeah I think a lot of
women would be turned off by that but
that just sounds like a them problem
like if you're the guy that girls want
to be with like they'll figure it out or
you'll find a different one
um
when you get married you're going to
have that kind of conversation like walk
me through the 30-second conversation if
you would there is no 30 seconds you're
not going to have one Community you're
not gonna have a talk with your girl hey
before we do this it's going to be ours
it's not gonna be 30. I get that but for
the sake of we have 10 minutes left for
the show let's not take hours give me
like the cliff notes version here the
cliff notes is listen I love you you're
the person I want to be with right we
have a lot of things that we need to
take care of for this marriage we have a
lot of paperwork that we need to do
wills power of attorneys all this stuff
one of these one of these documents is a
prenup right so uh you're going to have
your own attorney you're going to be
protected nothing in this prenup is set
to screw you over I love you I always
want to meet make sure that you are
provided for right you're going to have
your own attorney your attorney is going
to talk to you about it it's going to
read it to you you're going to
understand it perfectly you're going to
be protected there's your 30 seconds
that's how you do it but I appreciate it
you have to show it you have to present
it to her like hey this is not a a take
it or leave it type of thing even though
it is you're not going to present it
that way right because she she's your
you love her right you want her to be
your wife so you're going to present it
in a nice way but and it's it can take
30 minutes it can take an hour you're
not going to rush it through uh but
that's how you do it you do it with care
you're not an [ __ ] about it because
you love her but you need it done but
you need to get done bottom line is
before you get married you're getting a
prenup every yes you're getting a prenup
even though your husband
you might make more money than this
potential dude with the manatees coming
your way
got it have you guys had the prenup talk
have you guys had a marriage talk you
guys been together for a year are you
there yet do I just make it real awkward
yet yeah okay gotcha yeah is that
something you guys would discuss prior
to are you guys are just getting married
maybe yeah y'all never talked to y'all
not once talked about getting married
not once
you're on a relationship podcast yeah
not once have you guys talked about
getting married we've talked about if we
want to get married okay that's like far
in the future all right have you talked
about a prenup since you're talking
about marriage have you talked about the
prenup yeah you said that you wanted
prenup yeah okay that's excellent then
that's how it should be yeah
thank you thank you for that as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible